what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
god i'm kind of nervous to tell the
story because i really don't know how
the man of sphere
um is going to react
um but i want to tell you a story that
really
made me dislike men for
like a really really long time um
and really like made me feel like
violated so to speak
um this story everything that happened
was like legal
technically but there's just a lot of
stuff that was really like
messed up um in hindsight to me
okay i'm kind of nervous okay
um so anyone that's been like following
me
for a while knows that
i was an athlete and like sports was
super super important to me when i was
growing up
so um
i was always the type to like put in
extra hours at the gym i was always the
type to like work hard i
i'm like naturally pretty uncoordinated
but
i really like got to where i was
athletically just because i i worked
really really hard
so ah like i'm getting nervous okay
um anyways so when i was in high school
my mom hired a trainer and
that trainer um his name was marcus and
he was in the nfl
and he was like
i don't know like i my dad was gone a
lot when i was younger
and i'm never going to be the type to
say like
my dad wasn't there because he was
always there for like the big events
like the big stuff he was always there
for us i always knew that he loved us
um but there were times when he just
like wasn't around a lot because he was
running like a big software company
you know um so
at that time like i really looked at
this trainer
uh marcus as like a father figure like
i saw him maybe two or three times a
week so i got like it was a one-on-one
session so i got like really close with
him
um and like all the time and this was
when i started maybe when i was 15
um like going to see him a couple times
a week and he really helped me like get
to the next level of my sport whatever
um and in hindsight there were like a
couple conversations that stood out to
me that were kind of weird
but at the time when you're young like
it's kind of exciting when the adult
talks to you about like stuff that's
sort of inappropriate to be talking to
minors about
um like a conversation that stood out
was
i remember like saying something about
me being like
insecure you know when i was a kid
because when i was in high school like i
got zero attention from boys like boys
never never never talked to me so
and it's not even like the 80 20 thing
like guys just
never approached me ever talked to me i
went to a small catholic school
and i
said something to him about it and he
said like you'll get attention in
college
um and i forgot what he said but he like
i don't remember the exact words but he
heavily insinuated that like basically i
had a big butt
so i would get attention in college and
like to me this was just like a source
of validation
that i never really got like from
like anywhere outside of high school
um and there was just small things like
that where i would tell him about like
parties that like that i went to
or um like nothing big but like you know
just stuff like you
really should not be talking about like
underage drinking with an adult as minor
like that's inappropriate
but you know there's a lot of like other
stuff too that he just helped me with so
it wasn't like that was all we were
talking about but that there's just like
moments that are kind of weird in
hindsight once you're older and you look
back
like that was you as a child you know um
anyways
i like keep keeping on going with this
story
when i turned 18 or i was 17 when i left
for college so the last time i saw him
before i left for college i was 17
because
i was kind of young for my grade so when
i turned 18
i went to college and
um i did well my freshman year whatever
and the first time i went back to see
him
when i was 18
um he i like you know because
sorry this might sound weird if you
aren't in a sport but any like
former athlete knows the connection you
have with like a coach
um so he wasn't the only coach that i'd
go back and see like i went back and saw
my high school coach i saw a couple
club coaches and while i was at it i
went and saw my old trainer that was
really close with
that helped me get to where i was he
um texted me because i was just gonna go
see him at the gym he texted me to go
see him
at this like bar um but it was like
during the day so you could go eat there
too so i was like okay it's not that
weird like just going to get lunch with
an old coach
you know whatever um i i genuinely
didn't think anything of it
so i it was weird when i got there
because he was definitely like drinking
and he like sat at the bar
um but i just i was so naive guys like i
didn't
didn't think anything um
and he kept trying to get me to drink
because i was like kind of bragging that
i had like a fake id
and whatnot um
so
yes so he was like trying to get me to
use it and i i just
i wasn't the type to just like drink
with adults like i would just drink at
college i didn't drink when i was home
so i kept telling him no no i don't want
to do that
whatever and during the dinner or the
lunch
he just said things that were kind of
weird like
he would say like again making comments
about my butt
um asking if i had
um had had sex at that point like you
know just stuff that was inappropriate
and i thought was kind of weird
um but like in my head it was just
because we were like close
like this was the
you know father-like figure i don't know
it was
really weird in hindsight i don't know i
was dumb um
but anyways so i said like okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna go
um great to see you whatever left
he calls me on my way back and says hey
like you should just come to the gym
really quick
he owns the gym like it was his own
place and
i don't at first i said no but he's like
come on like
you should have a shot with me um
i don't know he like he kept asking me
if i want to have a shot with him
and in my head i i thought
i always felt like special like like
cooler than the other girls because he
was like the cool trainer
at like my club that i went to
so i always felt like like i'm the one
that he like gives extra attention to or
i'm the one that he
you know spends more time with like i'm
the one he believes in whatever i always
felt like cool so
i genuinely thought it would be cool to
like take a shot with
you know my old trainer and just brag
about it to my friends so
when i thought about it like that i was
like you know what
eff it like i'll go i'll go take a shot
and i'm gonna get going
um and
i have to say by the way he is i don't
know what his age was but like i would
say late 30s
early 40s um he had a daughter
that was my age which you know kind of
and he was married too so
that's why a lot of stuff that he did
that was weird like in my head
people don't cheat especially when
they're married and at that age like i
genuinely did not think that married men
cheated like genuinely didn't know
i'd never heard of anyone cheating um
yeah i didn't think it was a thing so
i go to
the i go to the
the gym right and i
he's like there sitting down and he's
just like making conversation with me
whatever
um and i'm we take the shot whatever
we talk probably for like half hour 45
minutes and he says
you know like this gem like we're alone
um we could do whatever you want
and i'm like what do you
what what do you mean marcus like and
he's like
what do you what do you think i mean and
i don't know why like
because there's a bunch of stuff that
led up to it but this was over
i'm 24 now so this was over five years
ago so i genuinely don't remember the
entire conversation
but like that part of the conversation
literally i will never i will never
forget
um and so then i just said you know what
marcus like i think i think i do
but i'm gonna pretend like i don't i'm
about i'm gonna get out of here
and then he's like texting me after i
leave like trying to get me to come back
and like have sex with him
and obviously like i left that was not
i was not about that um
but i came to find out that he was doing
this
not just with me like clearly but with
like a lot of other girls he would just
like
plant seeds until we were 18 and try to
hook up with the girls once they turned
18.
and it's just kind of messed up you know
and it was like heartbreaking to me
because this guy like
i looked at him as a father figure
um there were times where i was like
closer with him than like with my dad
and nothing against my dad you know um
we me and my dad like got closer after
this and like later on like now i'm like
super close with my dad
but yeah at that time i really wasn't
so it just kind of changed me the way
that i viewed the world because one i
didn't know people cheated i didn't know
that was a thing
two it made me second-guess a lot of
like coaches that had given me like
attention and help
growing up you know um it made me
kind of think maybe a lot of them were
creepier
than i thought before and
genuinely like i felt like i'd lost like
a friend which really sucked
um and then on top of that i actually
had to go get him fired from
my school because he was gonna start
coaching my younger sisters he was the
track coach at my high school
and i was not i'm not about to let him
coach my sister so i like literally
printed the screenshots and i brought it
to the school and was like look
i know i was technically 18 at the time
when he did this but this like isn't
right like he can't be grooming young
girls
to do that like that's that's messed up
um so i don't know that
that event like actually changed my life
like i never and that's when i started
to like
i don't want to say hate men but i
started to see it everywhere like i
would see all these guys like at my
school or at
you know like married guys just like
being super flirty with like younger
girls and it just
made me
sad you know um but i mean it's been
long enough like i'm cool now
but yeah that's that's the story
of how one guy
um made me think poorly of an entire
gender
for um maybe like two years it wasn't
that long but
year two years longer than it should
have so
i feel weird after that story telling
you to comment anything
but yeah thanks for listening if you
made it this far i'll talk to you guys
next time